- La situation se dégrade dit-
il.
Les chemins de fer ont été
endommagés.
Les files de véhicules se
dirigent vers l'est. Descendre
vers eux
Poutine est un type bien j'ai
été en Russie quand j'ai rendu
visite à mon petit-fils. Cette
autre femme pense que le Donbass
sera détruit que les Russes
installeront des armes
chimiques.
FRÉDÉRIC MÉRAND, direc., Centre
de recherches inter., U de M
- Il devient de plus en plus
évident que ce sera une guerre
d'u'u'u'u'u'elle va durer
longtemps. Le scénario le plus
probable depuis déjà quelques
semaines, c'est qu'il y ait une
partition de l'Ukraine, maispaps
reconnue ni par le gouvernement
ukrainien ni par le reste de
la communauté internationale.
- Le porte-parole ntntntntntnt
Poutine
admet les difficultés de son
armée. Il décrit le retrait des
troupes comme un acte de bonne
foi.
Dans sa cour arrière, Tatiana
montre la tombe de son fils et
de deux de ses amis. Difficile
pour elle de croire en un acte
oioioioioioioi.uiuiuiuiuiuiuis e
Denise. J'ai été obligé de
partir en 2014 pour sauver la
vie de mon fils. Il avait alors
14 ans. Comment est-ce possible?
Là où les troupes russes sont
passées les corps des victimes
ukrainiennes s'amoncellent.
Le président Zelenski affirme
que la situation
- le scénario encore personne
n'aurait été que la Russie qui
ne fournisse pas d'armement aux
ukrainiens. Ce soutien, la chef
de la diplomatie ukrainienne
Rexall plus rapide.